um well one of your goals now is to get
therapy taught to school kids like while
they're in school and I think you got
this all the way to the White House the
White House stepped into this yet right
yes how did how did because I remember
you talking Kenny and the thing you were
like I really want to do this I don't
know how to implement and I think it's
cool because you did Implement something
you wanted to do hopefully that is just
the beginning
um I think for me I learned so much in
the process and there's this behavior
therapy called dialectical behavior
therapy and I think it's you know it
sounds boring but it is uh it is a
program that helps you understand your
emotions and wise mind and all these
different things that you're kind of
walking through and I just figured when
you're young and you're in school they
they say are you happy face today are
you sad face and I feel like they should
just keep that going into others to
other grades yeah and I just feel like
it's it's a necessity just like physical
activity is and everything else it would
be I think it would be amazing if I
could make it happen yeah
wood no I will say this is what I
knocked for you I think it's it's crazy
cool too because my daughter she's in
second grade this year and she came home
and my son Remy was like he was having a
hard time with him and she goes oh buddy
you know what they have this this woman
I can't remember her name but there's
two of them and if you ever if you have
a hard time with that you can go talk to
them about it so anytime and I was just
like I I was tears I was just like I'm
doing good at something it's like I was
like because it's so cool that the
school's implementing that because to
have a kid going through a lot of things
and being a kid is hard I think what
you're doing is is perfect and and
important because to teach kids at a
young age that mental health is so
important and that's why we're still
talking about still going through these
routines is so important because I think
a lot of people would be better off as
adults so thank you I think it's really
worth fighting for yeah
[Applause]
[Music]